welcome to a spooky Halloween edition of
visual effects artist react we're going
to be looking at a bunch of gnarly Clips
but don't worry it's all fake you can
close your eyes if it get scary remember
it's just food coloring and corn
syrup oh dude this is so crazy with the
opening of ghost shap is spicy there's a
lot of tension pun intended you'll see
we're going to take a look at Sean of
the
Dead classic yeah this really is a
classic shot isn't it also we're going
to look at Bram Stoker's Dracula
starring Gary Oldman no visual effects
in that movie except for one shot
Halloween is not just for ghouls and
goblins and ghosts on
ships what an entrance we're going to be
looking at the 1980s hit classic
tolywood film Superman wait it's called
Superman it's called Superman okay okay
should it
be that's a question for another day all
[Music]
right
oh let's start with Ghost Ship because
ghost starts
[Music]
perfectly
uhoh God they anticipation legit oh it's
just going to behead them like chickens
in a coop huh do they do that I
think o oh the little iy that's
clever wow perfect editing that's how
ghosts are
made you start
oh feel it dude dude this is so crazy
they lived no they're the last to split
no she's holding him up oh he must have
been super
short oh my God he turns into a freaking
South Park there he turns into a
Canadian he turns into a Canadian that's
so
accurate wow Canadian ghost ship that's
crazy and then that's like a practical
head that they're projecting onto I mean
I think this is just solid really like
just really solid comp work but they
just cut out out that little bit of his
face from the footage and start moving
that and I think once it falls a little
bit far enough it cuts to a different
element that they got of him turning his
head forwards in fact you can see the
frame blend right there yeah it's frame
blending between the two that's great
and so what do you think that stump is
another element that they're just
compositing yeah it's just like you know
my cooked steak. PNG like you know love
that one I've seen the split in half
thing a million times but not on this
scale yeah you've never seen it split in
half a million times in one scene yeah
it's crazy got some good false floor
gigs going on like this arm shot like
that's the person under the floor yeah
but same with that shot with the woman
both her legs and her false floor the
previous shot of the guy cut in half
false floor really cool yeah this one
where the guy gets panted I think is a
little strange cuz you're just like that
is the least amount of
damage well so there's one issue so
clearly somebody thought this through
was like wait if a wire cut you in half
the bottom of your shirt would just fall
off but they forgot to account for the
fact that also his arms would fall off
that's so real oh wa no no no sorry I'm
wrong no no his he was dancing yes he
was dancing like this clearly turns out
I was the one dancing like this D my
go-to on the dance floor
yeah yeah but I'm not what I'm curious
about are why did his pants
fall why did his pants fall down was
that necessary wait go
back pants fall down where what are
those boxers are those is that
underwear it's like a one a onesie
almost I guess suspenders were holding
up his pants were they it doesn't make
any sense yeah you cut suspenders the
pants fell down too so conf but your
pants don't just fall
down is D it's honestly way cooler than
I expected it's a solid opening for a
movie yeah man I'm hooked yeah it's
pretty rad I like that scene it's really
gnarly
do you guys like it great mhm love him
Sha of the Dead classic hilarious
violent and uh they use visual effects
in this scene in a really uh fun way
this is it I'm going [__] off we've all
been here oh yeah this one
yeah classic yeah this really is a
classic shot isn't it really well
done gut through the
middle oh yeah BBE land on
it sorry I get excited so if you guys
were going to approach a shot like this
how would you do it I mean I would have
somebody stand up and do this action
ideally with something under their back
to guide them so they can keep it lined
up now the pole is comped pretty good at
the bottom ideally I would dig out the
ground and be pushing it up as the actor
goes up so you get realistic shadows and
interactions and stuff like that yeah
but there's too much in consistency on
it to move it I think you know with the
liquid it's not like a uniform
glossiness I think yeah you get too much
bump do you see how it was wiggling
though with her body feels like it's
interacting yeah I know I know it is
being pushed basically they're taking a
plate of the pole when it's at its full
extension and tracking it in and once
it's no longer moving they let it go
it's basically right about right there
that's like the element of the pole
they're using and they're tracking that
onto the pole that's being pushed you
are spot on yeah that's exactly how they
did it it's it's almost the same
technology as those uh those fake knives
that retract into themselves
retracts
sotru phography I think it's a practical
pipe I'm not sure if it's CG or
practical but also a blood element that
they shot on green spurting through the
pipe so that's all traditional comp
workk and then when she gets off at two
yeah you're totally right cuz you can
see on the pole there is texture right
if it was Immaculate reflection then it
could slide up and it wouldn't bother us
at all but when there's imperfection
when there's chunks of blood that don't
match chunks on top you do you totally
see the pole going up and then yeah you
see that hard one frame pop to the
actual pipe I mean you guys can maybe
lay down how they did looking through
her body cuz it's one take right there
is Parallax there is a moving camera and
they do land on the face through her
body which of course you couldn't
possibly see if she was blocking their
field of view yeah so how did they get
them in there it's funny cuz the faces
aren't in the same spot where they would
be and and honestly it doesn't even
matter cuz it doesn't like trigger
anything in you and you're not paying
full attention to it because again that
hole is so small that when you finally
do see their faces there is no Parallax
right the camera's kind of landed so all
you really need to do is a 2d track if
this was a much bigger hole and and you
were seeing The Parallax now you need to
match move you need to really do like
motion control or something to get like
a real good match but here you just get
away with a a single static plate that
you track in two simple two-point track
and then just uh rot out the hole and
then of course the only 3D element that
we have in there is is the center guts
of that hole the me yeah to give you
that that depth because without that
depth she'd look like a you know Paper
Mario or something um which would be no
good this is traditional practical
compositing very simply done and it has
all the impact if not more than a more
complicated approach would have so I
appreciate them them doing that
here all right so this movie is a little
interesting because it came out 1992
they were trying to do some cool effects
the effects team was like being like hey
let's shoot this let's do a green screen
here let's do this here and Francis f
Copo was like no I want to be done the
way that they did movies back in the
late 1800s I wanted to have that period
feel it's kind of same reason
Christopher Nolan stayed away from CGI
and Oppenheimer is he just didn't want
the visual effects to feel like they're
from a different era than the
film so it's a tiny miniature train set
25th May pest left be smoke that's kind
of cool that feels large I like that the
scale of that smoke feels very large you
know shooting Miniatures is obviously
like a cap as to how small you can get
and I imagine it's quite challenging to
recreate smoke in particular because it
acts like a fluid you know it's it's
growing and changing and the way forces
affect fluids obviously scale is very
very important to get the right look the
book is Big the book is big and it's
like a 12T by 15t book they wanted to do
this with Force perspective and like
some sort of split diopter so you could
focus in both areas but they weren't
able to get the shadow to work with the
force perspective and they're just like
you have to build a giant book and put
it right up against the train because
like we want the train to cast a shadow
on the book I love the the kiness of
this but when it's supposed to be like
heavy dark Dracula spooky stuff I'm like
it doesn't jive with that you know yeah
this is fun when you watch that shot
with a book you're like oh this is a fun
shot it's little like it's a very uh Tim
Burton
yeah yeah how would you do this shot
without any compositing uh so basically
what you do is you film your shot and
then you do a cool trick where you turn
off all the lights and put black
everywhere and then you film it again
with the same film stock you relight
your stuff a little bit there maybe
throw throwing some green lights roll it
over your same film you could
theoretically roll your take rewind the
film turn the lights off cover thing in
Black do the smoke that would
theoretically work as long as your
camera didn't move so that your pictures
would line up yeah but when the camera
moves it becomes a problem so here's a
little hint look at all that fabric
there just appears or in the previous
shot there's a little kind of like green
line you can kind of see the edge of
things are they using mirrors got it I
said mirrors for the last one can I just
grandfather it in I was about to say cuz
they got to be using mirr
so you have a piece of glass at a 45°
angle and they have the set duplicated
off to the side but everything's wrapped
in black dutin and so they just pour
smoke in and it's all lit with green
light and that piece of glass it's only
going to catch the bright stuff which is
the smoke and you're filming also
through the glass into the rest of the
set wow so you end up effectively doing
an optical composite live using that
piece of glass you can see the smoke
reflected over the set and because
everything's lined up it feels like the
Smoke's actually flowing through the set
wow man the creativity that's incredible
because like I'm watching these shots
and like you didn't need you didn't need
to do that yeah you could have just just
made one
set who the hell are you man I am
I I mean if we're going to do dra we
should to Mr morbius oh let's go we're
talking about the king of vampires
getting
away when they do the smoke Trails on
morbius it just makes it really hard to
read his body language and like his phys
ality it just comes a smear yeah it's
also this whole movie is dark too by the
way it's all dark vampires wearing black
motion blurred at night it does muddy
the action makes it hard to follow I
mean it already is hard to follow to be
totally honest yeah even in those slow
down moments it's so obscured it
actually reminds me of The Little
Mermaid conversation we were having
about the hair in the face uh just just
like pull up the bfx breakdown cuz they
they go through a a lot of these shots
and scenes with some breakdowns that are
pretty crispy look at that darkest guy
in the world on the darkest building on
the darkest night all that that detail
they put into it it's just Silhouettes
yeah yeah that's the thing that that
hurts me watching this is the simulation
work on the cloth is incredible and it's
buried yeah like this CGI is so robust
and then it is so dark look at all that
stuff that was there oh my God on the
day and
then delet it such a joke that literally
summed it up that was perfect just so
much effort dumped onto this shot yeah
once they got to he like okay it's a
little dark but it's not that bad right
you can still see most of it okay it's
not is actually not bad I can see most
of it it's pretty
cool the entire left side of the frame
disappears yeah all of it like who is
making the decision it's is so fun
heartbreaking like this is like the most
I I mean if you were going to make a
funny VFX reel this is how you do it you
show the 20 layers and then at the very
end you Fade Out yes and you're like
wait what was the shot we saw in the
movie it's like no it was that one
blurry black whip pan I did the left of
frame here I would be so sad and
honestly kind of insulted I would be
insulted straight up it's like
regardless of how good your colorist and
your cinematographer was it'd be like
you guys wasted my time you guys clearly
don't have things figured out I mean you
can make dark movies it's just when you
putting it out for television don't keep
it tuned the same way as if it's going
to professionally calibrated theater you
need to account for people not having
good displays like don't ruin your
audience's experience like don't forget
by the way someone did environment
design concept art for this location
before anyone even brought like a 3D
model into the mix oh my gosh the layout
work the modeling required dude I would
love I would love to hear from anyone
who worked on this shot if you are out
there how much time went into this
Halloween is not just for ghouls and
goblins and ghosts on ships all right
it's a time for Our Heroes it's a time
where we dress up in an outfit that
represents who we want to be and who
does everyone want to be Garfield okay
Garfield yeah that was a pivot besides
Garfield obvious answer Superman it's
alwaysi so yeah pick your poison there
I'm going to give you NT Rama Roo 1980s
South Indian
Superman this guy literally looks like
he's about to go trick- or-treating
like he's just missing his
[Music]
son the bullets not even mush he got the
whole theing he got theing he got the
shell maybe the bullet was put in
backwards put oh my gosh
classic oh that guy took a solid drop
kick I love his attack style though he
just leaps at everything wa oh get him I
freaking love this guy what's his
superpower it's like frog like stuff
he's got frog
motion what an
entrance oh my God he strips coming
through the window oh my God it's
amazing give me shades of
Steven oh this incredible oh my
gosh oh dude by the way yes this is
spooky that's spooky that's what I'm
talking about man I'm hella spooked yeah
happy Halloween
everyone oh hell yeah just like the
window freaking Hero's entrance Don oh
yeah hey that that's full
contact oh yeah oh did you just snap
that's how take him out baby dudee
what's what move is
that he doesn't even turn it at all po
one vertebrae and then zoom in but yeah
that's uh that is South Indian Superman
he's the one true Superman of me and uh
you can't change my mind yeah you know
it turns out this is the spookiest clip
out of all though yeah if you like
watching us go off the rails a little
bit and get more into the world of
making fun of videos rather than talking
about VFX well our website is right
where you want to go and Che out the
extended reacts there quarter
digital.com we don't make fun of anyone
they did this to
themselves oh hey uh get out of here
what are you still here for man the
video's over we'll see you next week